[Music]
do you
men make your bed
as soon as you wake up never ask my wife
i
do i we have a we have a uh rule
so ours is whoever gets out of bed last
makes the bed
that's that's awesome so what if you get
out together well that just makes sense
well then it's then we just take turns
so our ours our ways and that doesn't
make any sense hold on
what's your way did you make the bed
every time no it's it's i wake up
i'm not i'm not trying to throw you on
the bus here we go watch out
yes yes this is literally casey's
holding tip right now he's like i'm not
trying to throw you
in under the bus in front of the bus but
i'm winding up though
be careful choose your words carefully
casey first i wake up first just tell
the truth
and you won't have any issues the idea
is whoever
if you wake up you should just do your
half of the bed first
and so i'm supposed to do my half of the
bed
she rolls over and then she's like
messing up that's my logic
but i'm not gonna that's like yeah i'm
not gonna question her
do you guys have two blankets or one
blanket one like it then how do you do
one side first yeah what kind of
communism you tuck it in
you tuck it in because i don't need to
tuck it in
all it is is pulling it it's literally
like if this is the bed
right this is the bed yeah and then like
i'm on this side so i'm already having
can you guys see okay i have the
the thingy like this right yeah when he
got me he goes like this
and he just moves the blanket all the
way over to get out right to get out
perfectly fine whatever all i'm asking
is can you just pull this back like this
it doesn't have to be neat it doesn't
have to be tucked in the pillows
whatever
doesn't matter it's just only it's like
get it off of me put it back on your
side because
you should do that you should do don't
do that just [ __ ] keep it here and
then [ __ ] roll out
just just get out of the way hit the
ground
rolling yeah all i ask it's literally
like i'm here that's all
that's all i ask is just pull it back
you don't have to talk like pull because
then
when i ask then you start like pulling
the bed and then i start and i wake you
up
yeah and then like i don't have my sheet
anymore because you just tug the whole
thing and i'm like are you mad
because i'm trying and then her feet are
exposed and it's all cold it's winter
what about on the weekends do you guys
you still wake up before on the weekends
every day he wakes up at seven on the
dot and i wake up like around
8 39 and well now it's like more earlier
but yeah so i
just don't wake up when he wakes up so
that's all i ask is like just pull the
sheet back and that's it
but i so anyway i wake up and i'm the
one that actually fixes it up i fluff up
the pillows i do the whole
shebang all i'm asking is she's calling
him out right now wow calling him out
throwing him back under the bus
as well they just throwing each other uh
not gonna lie when i was living alone
i would never make the bed right i might
i might tuck the blankets a little bit
but in my head i'm like
man i'm just gonna crawl right back in
the bed like when like five minutes
later
no no later that night oh shia is a
make the bed everyday ass girl right so
it's like
now that we've been living together for
two years
um if i wake up last i will try and like
tidy the bed up a little bit you know
i'm saying re-fluff the pillows pull the
[ __ ] that's good
i use a [ __ ] flat sheet now i used to
i use a flashlight
like a hotel what does that mean this
thing the sheet that's
in between the uh the comforter okay i
don't know we don't do it
yeah so your dick stains don't get on
the blade keep the comforter
like fresher fresher it's the dick stain
protector
yeah to this guy no but it's the best
day in the summer
time because the duvet can get too hot
but then if you completely take it off
you still kind of want to be covered by
something and then the flat sheet is
like cool enough
to like keep you cool oh we have a flat
sheet i forgot i used to hate you tuck
it in though
no no no tuck you don't tuck it in like
a whole time look at it in the back no
i mean the ends bro when i sleep in the
hotel i [ __ ] kick all that [ __ ] me
too me too
god my feet have to stick out plus i'm
long so i i can't handle it you don't
want to go in like a ziploc bag
no i hate that my feet got to be out in
the open you actually like being tucked
in like
and and it's all it's glory of you you
took it your own
it's like a sleeping bag now i do now i
do i'm getting through the
corners are tucked in the blankets but
that's because i have a king-size
blanket on a queen-size bed now because
i used to have a king-sized bed oh so
you got some room
while it's tucked yeah it's not like
tightly tucked even if it's cold as [ __ ]
i have to have a foot out
same really can't be because i'm an
actual back has two zippers
it goes like this i'll unzip the bottom
and i'm like i still stick my foot out
it feels good dude that's true i think
it's like borderline claustrophobia or
something like i need to
just have like something hanging out
it's temperature because i'm naturally
just [ __ ]
radiating heat at all times yeah same
here it helps me i used to be but i'm a
cold ass
boy now man like you went opposite i saw
that i'm in that [ __ ] you saw that
yo i saw you go to your car like with
tickets
i'm [ __ ] cold now and like i curl up
into that [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] i'll have like layers of
blankets yeah i got this pillow that i'm
hugged up on and this one on the side of
me
sometimes i'll tell you what i'm even
under a pillow on my face dawg
i'm sleeping on a pillow and i got a
lighter pillow just on my face
because it just feels blasting we're not
we're not even blasting the heaters on
bro you don't radiate that much heat i
get not anymore i guess maybe something
happened as i got older maybe chia
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] me up why are you
so cold i don't know are you colder than
chia is
like is she like low key because i used
to run hot like you
yeah and then like i would be like uh
baby you got a soul
like you got it so hot in here you know
but after living with her for two years
now i'm like babe turn the heat on what
is it what do you
what is this i like being really cold
and then climbing into my bed yeah yeah
that helps me fall asleep
so i never get to the point where i'm
hot because the ac is blasting so hard
that the my i live in a refrigerator
hurt your
like your your nasal passageway because
when i was a kid
when it's way too cold in the air and
i'm like trying to go to sleep like i'm
all bundled up and i still have to
breathe
my freaking nose passage is like dried
out and really i think i got used to it
just from
sleeping outside and in the cold and
because when i was a kid though
i had that and then my nose would plug
up and [ __ ] i'm like i can't [ __ ]
breathe
so uncomfortable i could be dripping
with sweat from top to bottom
right but if nicki hasn't turned on the
ac i'm like there's no way i'm going to
bring it up
dude that's really yeah i'm not going to
bring it up first why no
because this woman is not going to beat
me if she's sitting there and she's fine
and i'm going to be like i need the ace
like then i somehow
you see it like some [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] wow
you guys ever you don't have a nest i do
have a nest because then you could just
secretly turn it on
i know but i couldn't pair it with my
phone because there's some password
that's too complicated
god damn it no it's just your gmail
account it's so hard to if you have no
idea because i never turn on the ac
i always do it on my phone and then joe
goes what the [ __ ] turn on the aca now
i don't know
yeah but i make my bed every day now
because i like to go home and go
damn that's a badass bed well when you
make your bed do you do it immediately
when you wake up or do you let your air
it's a routine now
i just get up and then um
i grab my bottle of water chug that look
at the bed
get the other side crawl on the other
side get the other side and then i weigh
myself
so that's kind of like my routine when
you have the bed like half of the
i guess the room psychology feels better
already oh yeah yes yeah
it looks it feels so much better walking
in yeah cause before my room was never
complete
so i never cared about it but then now
that it's complete i look at it and it's
a p
it's a part of the art right so i gotta
look at it and be like man this is
[ __ ] badass
we're in the sims and our little meter
goes up it feels nicer in there
it does my environment meter went up
that's true well i didn't play sims but
sure at least i'm not a [ __ ] with the
air conditioner huh my environment meter
just went up all right well the reason
why i bring up making your bed and stuff
is because there's this uh this lady on
instagram
she goes by mrs d's cleaning reviews
and so she she has like a like 60k
followers like she just talks about like
cleaning and stuff like tips cleaning
tips
and so she posted this she it says
it seems a lot of people get up and make
the bed straight away this is something
you need to stop doing
what uh i told you tia yeah she's gonna
go against navy seals
send this to my wife it says i'll send
this to my wife all the men all the
husbands are like
told you we're being anti-science right
now babe
so she says get out of bed and throw the
duvet back and let your bed
breathe all because of the moisture in
the butt exactly so she says
but it's not what this is for you go
like this and you air it out yeah oh
yeah i guess if you do that i do that i
don't do that because i know i'm a
sweaty [ __ ] so i can't just like
get out
and then because that's like me taking
off this shirt and the folding and
putting it back in there yeah it's gonna
get all gross and musky and
nasty that's true so she says during the
night we not only sweat but we also shed
skin and this is a magnet for dust
mites and bed bugs they love damp and
humid areas
and some people only let their bed
breathe in the summer and i think
that you don't need to do this i'm sorry
and think that you don't need to do this
in the winter because of the cold
weather but this isn't true with central
heating being on in the winter it can
attract dust mites and bed bugs just as
much
as in the summer months so by making
your bed first thing every morning you
are trapping all that damp air and
helping dust mites slash bed bugs breed
sounds horrible but it's true to help
reduce dust mites and bed bugs here are
a few tips
air out your bed for at least an hour
every day i know it's nice to see your
bedroom looking clean and fresh and of
course we
lead busy lives which means it's easy
to make the bed before you go to work
but doing this will help a lot if you
don't have an hour in the morning leave
it till you get home and make the bed
then at least you know it's had a good
airing
number two wash your sheets once a week
using a high wash cycle and a laundry
cleanser
this will kill any bacteria on your
bedding number three
once a month deep clean your mattress by
vacuuming it and
back vacuuming it and then using a steam
cleaner to kill all bacteria and dust
mites steam cleaner two
dude who does this [ __ ] once a week who
washes your sheets once again she does i
like i like how she took away one chore
and then we're like yes and it's but
there's 12 other [ __ ] chores yeah
exactly the original chore and you have
to set a timer too to [ __ ] air your
bed out and then
an hour goes by and then you can put it
away let me tell you the last one uh
wash your duvets and pillows every six
months if you can fit them in your own
washing machine
if you can't fit them in your own
washing machine then take them to the
laundrette
or cleaners most cleaners offer a duvet
cleaning service
so those are the tips i was just going
to ask you guys how often you wash your
sheets
every week i really want to say it's
embarrassing so here's the thing
our cat likes to pee my [ __ ] gets brown
okay
our cat pee's on our bed now because we
have these new kittens around so they're
trying to establish territory or some
[ __ ] yeah so we
wash them like once a week because of
that before that
it was like once a month probably yeah i
um
now like chia's thing every sunday
stripped the bed
and the pillowcases wash it but that's
like that's like hershey she needs to do
this well don't you like
the clean sheets it feels good i love
the clean sheets it's amazing i love it
and i feel
nasty when i'm living in the nasty
sheets it's just
it's a lot it's a lot i used to never
wash my sheets unless she
like was coming for her monthly visit
that was like the only time i watched
what i do is just get do a big batch and
then have multiple sheets
so then you just get fresh ones and you
just put your old we have
so many sets of sheets you just never do
it it's the part of like
pulling it out no the pulling out of
these like the duvet
like i hate setting up the duvet like
the the way we do it the rolling it up
well that's actually the easiest
way to [ __ ] i hate the duvet the sheets
i hate the [ __ ] duvet you got to
stick it in there
okay listen listen listen we type the
strings all right
we try the string no i mean obviously
you tie the strings no i'm saying that's
not the easy part
okay what you do is you get your duvet
cover
okay the cover goes inside out
you lay it flat down on your bed then
you get your duvet
and then you put it over the cover you
make sure it lines up neatly okay
you start at the top and you make sure
that the opening is here at the bottom
you start at the top you roll in the
duvet
so outside of the duvet cover you roll
it in all the way
until you get to the cup you put it on
like a condom and then
you grab the opening like this and then
you bring it
inside out i can't do it you lost me
[ __ ] this i'm out
[ __ ] easy
the hardest part right which is like
getting the opening and then putting it
inside out
and then once you put it inside out you
can't even deal with tissues i know i
can't do it with tissues but listen you
put it inside out
and then you roll this [ __ ] out and it's
like all together i can't do it
not together at all it's together and
it's easy and you're done
you want to do a race you know what the
easiest thing i'm down i'm gonna race
you on our vlog channels
i'll [ __ ] do it like this i'm down
you just throw away your duvet that's
the easiest way buy a new one
it's too thick for me man i got a thin
blanket it's perfect
no no my thread count is high you get
um one blanket and then you just put
some of those mexican blankets like the
what like the like the poncho materials
dude i've been there i'm not going back
no but i love a nice thick duvet me too
it's comfortable but it's too thick i
grew up with just a flashy in the
mexican place i can't go back
the thick poncho material that feels
like straight up
like woven [ __ ] basket
put down you're not selling that no
you're not that [ __ ] on the feet to send
a [ __ ] swat team in for me dude
because i'm never going back
especially with that buffy and with the
new sheets the
entitude oh they're bombs why don't you
do this tiff why don't you buy
30 sheets put it all on top of each
other
and then you just rip one
oh they actually sell those they sell
those for the bed like the mattress
there is an actual product where you
just peel away the sheet and you throw
it away
i can't wait for you guys to duvet cover
race i can't wait to fall asleep during
this video
we have to start with the corners
already tied up though damn
what the gauntlet has been thrown it's
gotta start with the [ __ ] in the
in the uh the dryer dryers do it
you gotta pull it out you gotta start on
your bed you gotta wash it
and then you wait an hour that's the
whole video yeah we gotta start asleep
at 10 pm that's good and then wake up
and do it
[Music]
do